-Performing "Petty Too" and
"Ahhh Ha" from his new album,
"7220," give it up for Lil Durk,
featuring Future!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-IRoccOnTheBeat.
-Who made this...Pharaoh?
-Yeah.
-♪ He got caught with a... he
hit like twice but he denied ♪
♪ I put my... ♪
♪ He thinking with his...
so he gon' slide ♪
♪ You can't call me petty,
me I share my...with the guys ♪
-♪ I got...who I...and they got
names, but I can't brag ♪
♪ You wanna fly out your friend
you better be ready with her ♪
♪ They never put me on blast
'cause I'm not petty with them ♪
♪ I did a show five
hundred thou', ask Bands ♪
♪ I got my Patek bigger ♪
♪ Back to Miami, got her...
on fleek she got her... ♪
♪ She hit me,
her price low ♪
♪ I like trenches who sell
they lean card for they micros ♪
♪ I be in the trump
stuffing my Runtz up ♪
♪ With my white... ♪
♪ Pop out daytime, but we
pop outside at night, though ♪
♪ Petty ♪
♪ If you petty,
then I'm petty too ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ If you petty,
then I'm petty too ♪
♪ If you ready,
then I'm ready too ♪
-♪ Let's get it ♪
-♪ If you petty,
then I'm petty too ♪
-♪ Let's get it ♪
-♪ If you petty,
then I'm petty too ♪
♪ Cutting off my partner,
was thinkin' trappin' ♪
♪ Wasn't no hobby ♪
♪ Drop you off the label, you
ain't ready to catch a body ♪
♪ Plugged up like cable ♪
♪ You gon' think
I'm Black Mafia ♪
♪ Sub twins,
soon as we catch up ♪
♪ Nine dollar ♪
♪ Whack that...
have his family ♪
♪ Writing me a novel ♪
♪ Went to Louis Vuitton just to
show off my Balenciagas ♪
♪ Get mop from a prostitute,
I feel her teeth ♪
♪ She ain't gettin' a dollar ♪
♪ My younger 22,
she don't keep it P ♪
♪ I'mma...her mama ♪
♪ She ain't just for the street,
these...for the Earth ♪
♪ I knew she was a freak,
she grew up in a church ♪
♪ These girls poppin'
Plan B's like they Percs ♪
♪ Said I was a deadbeat when I
bought my daughter a Birkin ♪
♪ If you petty,
then I'm petty too ♪
♪ If you ready,
then I'm ready too ♪
-♪ Let's get it ♪
-♪ If you petty,
then I'm petty too ♪
-♪ Let's get it ♪
-♪ If you petty,
then I'm petty too ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
♪♪
♪ Don't respond to...with Von ♪
♪ I'm like...you tripping ♪
♪ Go get your... ♪
♪ They dropping locations ♪
♪ We get it, it done ♪
♪ Tweeting, we sliding ♪
♪ The feds will come ♪
♪ He...his... ♪
♪ Them...his sons ♪
♪ I'm hanging with... ♪
♪ We breaking a bond
♪ They really don't mean it ♪
♪ He say it in songs ♪
♪ He play it in songs ♪
♪ They been sliding through
they blocks ♪
♪ And they don't know we have ♪
♪ And we ain't claim it,
but I can show... ♪
♪ Acting like they really
like that since my brodie died ♪
♪ Just got out the feds ♪
♪ You bring up murders
with your police... ♪
♪ I told Von to leave that ♪
♪ She post on OnlyFans ♪
♪ Catch 'em at the apartments ♪
♪ They been in 'cause that's
our only chance ♪
♪ Like they, they on the Gram ♪
♪ Old opps messing with
my new opps ♪
♪ I get merched,
we been through there ♪
♪ That...like ghost land ♪
♪ My brother DThang just got...
and I been slow since ♪
♪ But we got back on they... ♪
♪ I bet they know this ♪
♪ And, on bro,
I'm speaking facts ♪
♪ This ain't no diss ♪
♪ Keep the police
out my business ♪
♪ We don't post ♪
♪ Trigger Happy,
I be with Zoo 'nem ♪
♪ And we on... ♪
♪ They like,
"Durk, his...a singer ♪
♪ He won't smoke ♪
♪ You can believe
whatever you want ♪
♪ I got your folks hit ♪
♪ Ahhh ha,
don't respond to...with Von ♪
♪ I'm like you tripping ♪
♪ Go get your... ♪
♪ They dropping locations ♪
♪ I'm getting it done ♪
Know what time it is.
Shout-out to Future
here just one time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Shout-out to Jimmy.
Know what time it is.